for a year and a half i've been trying
to figure out unreal engine ever since i
saw the qixel rebirth trailer that blew
everyone's minds i knew i had to figure
out this program and over the last year
and a half i dabbled in unreal engine
but yielded just okay results i wasn't
happy with the progress i made and
ultimately just stuck to my go to 3d
program left wondering how people got
beautiful results like this
but recently i felt something click with
my latest project so i'm here to fast
track your unreal engine progress by
breaking down my latest project and
sharing everything i know in this one
video to help my past self and everyone
else asking how do i just make awesome
art in unreal engine
now before we begin i have to mention
there's no way i would have gotten this
far in my unreal engine journey if it
weren't for the help of great teachers
and friends starting with steve begin
who took a couple hours out of every
friday morning to answer my questions
jonathan winbush who somehow has a
tutorial ready for every unreal question
i ask sam at rococo who picked up the
phone every time i called to help
troubleshoot
and recently william foshea whose
tutorials have been a godsend during
this project i've linked these artist
pages below because if you're trying to
dive deep into unreal engine or even
just understand what this hype's all
about they got you covered and finally
to epic games for sponsoring this video
which is about the coolest freaking
thing to happen to a video like this
unreal engine is free to download so if
you want to follow along click the link
in the description to get your download
going right now waste no time then watch
this video again to test all this stuff
out it's a blast
so without further ado let's make some
awesome art
these images were made as a tribute to
the late ambient artist mount shrine for
his posthumous collab album with
musician sky too high the full 10 minute
music video will drop later this month
in honor of caesar whose work
skyrocketed the bar for ambient music
for me personally now music is actually
my number one way to generate visuals so
the first thing i did was listen to
their album imaginary pathways which
i've linked below it inspired images of
nightlife flashing lights and even old
90s video games so i gathered references
compiled them in pref and use them to
create this custom concept frame
i love this workflow because it
efficiently guides me towards my project
specific goals
so let's hop into unreal engine and turn
this rough concept into a cinematic
scene optimizing your unreal engine
project to look as good as possible
actually starts from this point the new
project window
each one of these templates toggles
certain in-engine settings on or off
depending on what you're trying to do
they can be switched back on later so no
worries i'll walk you through everything
starting with enabling rage tracing and
if you have an rtx card that supports
ray tracing and your computer can handle
it then this is a no-brainer it's the
best way to ensure you're getting the
nicest results from unreal engine let's
enable starter content too which starts
us off with some objects and materials
to make life easier let's open our
project and ensure that ray tracing is
set up properly by navigating to edit
project settings
type ray tracing into the search bar and
confirm the ray tracing box is checked
halfway there if you go to platform
windows you must ensure directx 12 is
chosen with the directx 11 and 12 box
checked you'll be wondering why ray
tracing isn't working properly like i
was if these steps aren't followed
in order for us to optimize our settings
and yield the best cinematic results
we need to begin with a lit scene to
point a camera at so let's start
building drag out a floor object from
our starter content folder navigate your
space by holding right click and
pressing either w a s or d just like
you're in a pc game
q and e will raise and lower the camera
while pressing f snaps your viewport to
any selected object now this slider at
the top right of your viewport that
controls your movement sensitivity while
the options to the left toggle snapping
for position scale and rotation let's
grab some more walls and basic shapes
from the place actors window hold alt to
duplicate things until you have what
you're going for
and be sure to organize everything in
your world outliner it can get really
messy really quick it's very important
you organize your stuff
now i always use a human sized figure
for scale when building things out at
first
you can grab that for free along with a
ton of other assets and full demo scenes
from the unreal marketplace it's a great
way to reverse engineer beautiful scenes
and learn through experimentation once
you check out you can add the asset to
your scene and bam we got a character
for size reference
at this point things are getting a
little dark so let's grab a couple
spotlights to backlight our standing djs
with
now color and intensity pretty
self-explanatory but attenuation radius
that's used to control how far the light
travels you can change the inner and
outer cone length for different looks as
well
but i want to add a custom light fixture
so i made this in cinema 4d brought it
into unreal engine and used an emissive
material on the bulbs to give a techie
look to the scene and since i'm using a
handful of emissive materials in this
scene let me show you how to set up a
simple light emitting material with
color and intensity sliders
let's right-click in the content browser
and create a new materials folder inside
we'll right-click to make a new master
material which i'll name mm emissive
light right click that and create a
material instance titled mi emissive
light
so the material instance is what will
apply to objects in our scene to keep
performance up and load times during
adjustments down
as opposed to applying the master
material to everything which takes way
longer to process make changes to
ultimately slowing down your scene but
we got to build the master material
first in order to easily edit material
instances so let's double click the
emissive light master material to hop in
and already this window might look
familiar to anyone who's made a material
before in blender or octane or redshift
we're going to plug different nodes into
their respective channels starting with
a color value
so hold three and left click in the
empty space to create a constant three
vector which is just an rgb value
now in order for this node to show up in
our material instance we need to promote
it to a parameter parameters are the
things you can adjust in the material
instance
if i don't promote this to a parameter
i'll have to open this master material
up every time hit save and it'll take
like five seconds which is way too long
so let's name it color to control
intensity let's hold m on your keyboard
and left-click to create a multiply node
and hold s and left-click to make a new
scalar parameter which we'll call
intensity to control our intensity in
the material instance pipe it into
multiply b the color into multiply a and
all that into emissive color don't
forget to save and done
let's apply our material instance to the
custom light bulb we created and double
click the instance to open it up you'll
notice the color and intensity
parameters on the right based on the
parameters we created in our master
material choose an intensity choose a
color and have fun
now the scene is looking and needs some
atmosphere
so look at the difference this is about
to make in the place actors window type
exponential height fog and get it all up
in your scene scroll down to the
volumetric fog checkbox and slap it on
film sets they usually add a bit of fog
or atmosphere to achieve this subtle
look both indoors and out so it's no
different in our 3d scenes let's scroll
back up and adjust the fog density
slider oh but it caps out at .05 we want
more so type in a bigger number and
break the rules it looks nice
and lastly
we're getting weird results in the
corner over here so set the fog in
scattering color to black
perfect fixed
now this is a live show setting we're
creating
and what live show doesn't have awesome
visuals to accompany the music so let me
show you how i set up an emissive video
screen to play any video you want
let's make a videos folder
and drag an mp4 video file inside
right click navigate to media and click
new media player
check the video output media texture
asset box
let's open it up and double click on the
video we just dragged in
save and close now you'll notice an
underscore video asset was created if we
drag that out onto say a flat plane that
can act as a screen a new master
material will be created and
automatically apply itself to our plane
let's double click the master material
to make a couple adjustments you can see
that the texture sample node is
referencing the media player video we
just created and is piped in to the base
color now if you want a challenge
pause the video here and set up an
intensity parameter for this texture and
pipe it into the emissive color
otherwise let's create a multiply node
by holding
m and left clicking and a scalar
parameter with s plus left click
we can name that screen brightness and
pipe it into multiply b the texture into
multiply a and then multiply into a miss
of color and hey if you got something
close congratulations let's go ahead and
save and close
create a material instance by right our
master material and clicking on create
material instance
double-click the instance and notice the
screen brightness parameter we just set
up but how do we get this video screen
to play in our viewport because right
now it's not and even if we hit the big
play button on the right and hop into
our level we still get nothing and plus
i'm not trying to make a playable level
i want to render some nice cinematics
now if you're familiar with davinci
resolve adobe premiere final cut unreal
engine has something similar built in
that allows you to add layers clips and
anything else you want to edit or
animate it's called the sequencer and
it's crucial for not only exporting
sequences but being able to playback
what you're working on
so let's make a sequence
right click and make a sequence folder
inside we'll right click go to animation
and create a new level sequence double
click it and let's hop in together
since our movie screen is the first
thing that needs to be queued up and
played in our scene let's right click in
our sequence window and make a media
track so we can add
our media player asset now by default
this doesn't fill the entire timeline so
you'll need to drag it out to the end
now if you scrub the timeline you'll
notice it's still not playing so right
click your media track go to properties
and choose your media texture video
now if you scrub or hit play things
should be working nicely
open your material instance and adjust
the screen brightness too
now if you're trying to get this video
to play in your real time level the
process is a bit different there's a
tutorial in the description if that's
what you need but to make playback
easier let's toggle the cinematic
viewport by clicking perspective in the
viewport and choosing cinematic viewport
right at the bottom
so now that we have a small scene to
work with let's lock in our camera
settings ever since i started this
channel back in 2006 i've been making
live action short films and making my
short films look like real movies was
and always will be the goal and i've
found that my knowledge of real world
cameras actually translates to 3d art so
if you're a 3d or vfx artist and have
access to a cheap dslr or even a cheap
35 millimeter film camera definitely
grab one start shooting and i promise
you're gonna learn a lot you have a lot
of fun and all that knowledge will
translate into 3d as well so let's start
breaking down these cinematic camera
settings in unreal engine in the place
actors window let's search for cine
camera actor drag it out and right click
it to pilot the camera nowadays movies
are usually filmed in a two three five
to one or two three nine to one aspect
ratio
in other words
they're super wide screen that specific
aspect ratio is usually always wider
than the tv screen or computer monitor
it's being displayed on which is why you
get empty space above and below the
image these black bars are so crucial to
the cinematic look people are slapping
them over anything to look legit while
it's not the end-all be-all to make your
janky iphone shot cinematic it can
certainly help so these cinematic bars
are achieved by setting your aspect
ratio to somewhere between 235 and 239
so with your camera selected come down
to the film back settings
make sure it's set to custom
and enter 64 for the width 27 for the
height
and you'll notice the axe width ratio is
set to 237 which is perfectly between
our two filmic aspect ratio options
but what about depth of field let's lock
that in so think of these lens settings
here as the boundaries in which our
camera can operate if you're trying to
zoom out to a 16 millimeter but can't
it's because you chose a 24 millimeter
to 70 millimeter lens to attach to your
virtual camera for the most freedom go
with universal zoom which gives us the
ability to play between four millimeters
and a thousand millimeters and stop all
the way down to a 1.2
now if you know real world lenses the
aperture or f-stop same thing is
essentially the amount of light that's
let into the lens the more light that's
let in the blurrier out of focus
elements are
so to get that nice blurry background i
keep my minimum f-stop at 1.2 though you
can set it to like .95 or below if you
want to crank it just depends on the
shot
to focus on something specific leave
your focus method on manual check the
draw debug focus plane box and work the
manual focus distance to find your
subject
or you can set your focus method to
tracking open the tracking focus
settings and eye drop anything you want
to focus on regardless of where the
camera is
so now that we decided our min max
camera settings let's pick something
that looks nice like
50 millimeters with a 1.2 aperture nice
but let's improve your depth of field
quality with a cheat code yes unreal
engine has cheat codes to make things a
little bit more confusing
just pull your escape key on the top
left of your keyboard is the tilde key
hit that to open up your console command
menu
type r dot temporal a a
dot up sampling zero shout outs to
william faulchey for this one he made a
whole video going into how and why this
looks better which you can find in the
description
next up we have frame rate which is
super important to getting that filmic
look
movies operate at a standard 24 frames
per second since we're making movies hit
the tilde key and type t dot max fps
24 this locks your viewport frame rate
at 24 frames per second so you can get a
feel for your final export the last
thing we'll control in camera is
exposure because unreal defaults to auto
exposure and we want manual control over
what our exposure does so to turn off
auto exposure let's click settings
project settings type exposure and
uncheck auto exposure let's change auto
exposure histogram to manual then in our
camera settings under post process let's
open exposure and toggle metering mode
as well as exposure compensation and
regardless of your metering mode setting
you should now be able to adjust the
exposure to your liking
unreal engine is a deep program and i
have thrown a lot at you so far and
we're not done yet we still got to talk
about export settings but if y'all are
still with me i just want to say thank
you
y'all are the ones who really care about
this stuff if you really enjoy this
content consider subscribing i do a lot
of deep dive content like this in the
world of 3d vfx and storytelling and if
you want to get your hands on all of my
assets project files and more check out
my patreon to see if that's for you but
let's dive back into unreal engine
because there's still settings we gotta
tweak to get the most out of this
program earlier we enabled ray tracing
but how do we fine tune its settings to
get the cleanest results one thing you
need to know that took me forever to
figure out is that your viewport view is
just a low res sample of what you'll
really be exporting so no worries if
you're like why doesn't this look 100
well one reason is because you don't
have a post-processing volume in your
scene where we can control bloom bokeh
shape color correction film grain and
most importantly tweak our graphical
settings
let's drag out a post process volume
from the place actors window
now by default is restricted to this
little box but we want to tweak the
global settings not just settings for
this tiny little area so with the post
process volume selected let's search for
unbound and toggle infinite extent
by the way you can hit g to toggle icons
on and off if that's helpful for you all
right so let's drop down lens and work
on our bloom settings
you can take method intensity and
threshold to fine-tune them bloom is
important because it's a real world
camera attribute that occurs when things
get really bright in dark areas the
scene would be lame without bloom and
using bloom convolution actually allows
you to choose custom bloom shapes by
switching out the kernel but personally
i didn't go that far with this scene
next under image effects i like to add a
little vignette to simulate real world
lens vignette which is actually
something you'll see removed from
photographs or footage but i think it
can help draw the eye to the center of
the frame but be subtle with this
grain is another one that you can toggle
to dirty up your super clean footage
this is so important so important that
i'll actually render without grain so i
can add super specific film grain from a
pack or something in davinci
but if you don't have that option this
is way better than not having any
so add it
but again be subtle
motion blur is next so if we drop down
rendering features we can adjust our
motion blur
i like to keep mine film standard which
is technically double your frame rate in
our case it's 24 fps so 1 over 48 or
180 degrees in other words just set your
amount to 0.5 and you'll be good in most
situations
now i love
me some crispy reflections
and had a heck of a time trying to clean
them up
i actually had my directx settings on
directx 11 and my reflections were
looking like booty so sensei steve was
like nah man directx 12 if you're trying
to enable ray tracing so open up ray
traced reflections in your post process
volume and make sure you have enough
bounces
two works for my scene but if you want
to see reflections in reflections in
reflections you'll need to creep that
number up to two three
four bounces etc until you're happy the
samples per pixel also makes a huge
difference i'll usually just keep
doubling the number until i'm happy with
the result or until my frame rate drops
significantly
which you can see by the way by going to
the top left viewport and checking show
fps
you can always boost the samples per
pixel before export though so pick
something that keeps your frame rate up
until then now that's all i'm doing as
far as post process settings go but if i
missed anything please leave a comment
down below i learn stuff from you guys
all the time
now there's two more things i want to
talk about before this video wraps all
right first is how i captured custom
mocap data brought it into unreal engine
and cleaned things up and the second
thing is my final export settings and
all the cheat codes i use to push our
render beyond what we're seeing in the
viewport so since this is a dance club
we need to get some 3d characters
dancing so that means it's time to bust
out the rococo mocap suit strap on the
gloves and crank up the jams y'all i
danced i danced my little legs right off
we're talking like 10 minute takes i do
this over and over and over again until
i have enough 10 minute takes to fill a
dance club but there's only so much
dancing one man can handle so i recorded
a few looping animations as well to fill
out the crowd
so to get this custom mocap data out of
rococo and into unreal i'll first
reprocess using rococo's awesome filters
and export a miximo skeleton because i'm
about to pair this data with a miximo
mesh so on miximo i'll search for t-pose
then download the characters in t-pose
that i want to attach to the custom
mocap data i just recorded so in order
to pair any character to any animation
we have to import everything in a
specific order drag one character fbx
into an appropriate folder which will
cue the fbx import options now we can
leave everything blank but i got to
point out this used t0 as ref pose check
box
now to my knowledge since the t-pose is
the entire pose not just on frame zero
we technically don't need to check this
box but if your fbx is animated with the
t-pose only on frame 0 then you'll
definitely want to check this box that
way you can pair this character up with
other animations
i'll check this though because
it doesn't hurt to and important in our
characters folder we see a skeleton was
made this is the asset we'll use for any
and all characters and animations we
import from here on out so when i drag a
new character in we'll make sure the
skeleton is set to t-pose james skeleton
sharing that skeleton allows us to swap
freely between characters and animations
otherwise we'd have to do this one by
one for like a hundred plus characters
and that's just not possible
now when we import the custom mocap data
which i'll batch drag and drop
we again want to ensure we're using that
same t-pose james skeleton
and import all so far so good but if we
compare the base t-pose character to the
animated character one looks normal and
the other looks like gumby so let's fix
this double click the animation data and
go to frame one t-pose to fix the long
neck syndrome click options just above
the bone tree and select show
retargeting options
select all your bones with ctrl a right
click and select recursively set
translation retargeting skeleton bam
the neck is fixed but now the characters
floating and has these football
shoulders
so to fix the floating just set the hips
to animation scaled to fix these
shoulders drop the shoulder bones by 30
degrees and raise the arm bones by
another 30. that balances things out but
if you save and close these arm changes
won't stick you need to make a keyframe
then hit apply if you want to make more
tweaks you certainly can but for my club
scene the simple neck and shoulders fix
will do just fine and just a final note
that you'll need to do this for each
unique animation
but now you can change out the character
by changing the skeletal mesh as well as
the animation they're performing by
ensuring animation mode is set to use
animation asset
now wind bush's tutorials on character
stuff in unreal engine really helped me
figure out some of this stuff so
definitely look for his channel in the
description if you're trying to dive
deeper into all of this
and finally we've come to the last bit
of this epic tutorial export settings
and we're going to use the movie render
queue to control those export settings
the movie render queue says forget real
time let's crank these settings to get
the best looking images possible
in order to get the movie render queue
running we need to enable the plugin by
going to settings plugins typing movie
render and checking both of these
options here once you do so you'll be
prompted with a restart then you can go
to window cinematics movie render queue
let's click the green render button and
select our sequence
now to tweak the export settings let's
click on unsaved config to open up the
settings and presets window by default
we're exporting a jpeg sequence but if
you want as much control over your image
for color correction say in davinci
resolve or premiere pro i would
definitely export an exr sequence and
untoggle the jpeg
you can check multi-layer if you want to
include other render passes in your ear
xr as well let's add some anti-aliasing
as well which really helps clean up
motion blur samples and steppy edges
there's two different kinds of
anti-aliasing but for this project i'm
using 64 temporal samples and checking
the override anti-aliasing button
so there is a ton to get into like how
and why all this stuff works but this
video would be two times longer if i dug
any deeper than this so if you want to
get into this stuff and really
understand all of it read the
documentation for the movie render queue
i got you with a link in the description
it's really well written easy to
understand and they do a fantastic job
of guiding you through each and every
detail and finally we have console
variables the cheat codes that let you
crank your settings on export
now i got all of these console variables
from that documentation link i just
mentioned so
check it out so you can copy paste all
this stuff into your projects so these
top five turn off any denoising that
occurs while ray tracing is enabled
already things will be a little more
crisp the next four commands are
recommended to be set at zero when we're
running our current anti-aliasing
settings and this chunk of console
variables
are telling the engine to crank motion
blur depth of field bloom and tone map
settings to
their max
remember when we adjusted our ray traced
reflection samples per pixel in our post
process volume well i have that as a
console variable as well
where we can take this number way higher
than it is in our viewport the final
console variable i have for you
is r dot screen percentage this one is
huge because what it's doing is
essentially rendering a higher res
version of your image than scaling it
back down to your output resolution
so if we're exporting a 1920 by 817
which by the way is that cinematic
aspect ratio we went over
r dot screen percentage 100 keeps things
at default
but if we set r.screen percentage to 200
unreal will render a 3840x1634
image two times the resolution but scale
that down to fit your original
resolution
it improves your sharpness like crazy
and is definitely a console variable you
don't want to miss out on and with all
that we finally find ourselves in the
output settings
set your directory set your resolution
check the box for a custom frame rate of
24 fps
hit accept
and render your scene
you are all champs for making it this
far into this video it feels so good to
finally get a grasp on this program
after a year and a half and i know that
you can too click the link in the
description and download unreal engine
for free
whether you're making real-time games or
photoreal cinematics unreal engine has
something for everybody and subscribe to
this channel so you don't miss out on
the 10-minute music video that i put
together from this project i also got a
couple more deep dive videos before the
year's end so stay excited stay
passionate and i'll catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you